now let's think about expressions with
more than one variable so say i had the
expression a
plus
a plus i'll do a really simple one a
plus b
and i want to evaluate this expression
when a
is equal to seven
and b
is equal to two and i encourage you to
pause this and try this on your own
well we wherever we see the a we would
just replace it with the seven and
wherever we were see we see the b we'd
replace it with the two so when a equals
seven and b equals two this expression
will be seven
plus two which of course is equal to
nine so this expression would be equal
to nine in this circumstance let's do a
slightly more complicated one
let's say we have the expression
x
times
y
minus y
minus y
plus x
plus actually let's make it plus
3x or another way of saying it plus 3
times x
so let's evaluate this when x is equal
to
when x is equal to
three
and y is equal to two and once again i
encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own
well everywhere we see an x let's
replace it with a three every place we
see a y let's replace it with a two so
this is going to be equal to
3
times y and y is 2 in this case
3 times 2
minus 2
plus
plus this 3 times x but x is also now
equal to 3. so what is this going to be
equal to well this is going to be equal
to
3 times 2 is 6.
this 3 times 3 is 9. so it simplifies to
6 minus 2 which is 4
plus 9 which is equal to 13. so in this
case it is equal to 13.